On paper, Solo: A Star Wars Story wasn't the
worst idea.
But in practice, the project didn't really
work out.
The Han Solo Star Wars prequel was released
in May 2018 to a less-than-enthusiastic reception,
becoming one of the worst-performing movies
in the entire series.
Far from the billion dollar heights of The
Force Awakens, Solo brought in only about
$393 million at the global box office a shockingly
low sum for what used to be the biggest movie
franchise in the world.
Prior to the launch of Solo, it was reported
that Disney was working on other spinoffs
focusing on different characters from the
franchise, including Obi-Wan Kenobi and Boba
Fett.
The Boba Fett movie was even reported as having
a writer-director attached in James Mangold,
who previously helmed the well-received Logan
in 2017.
But after Solo crashed and burned, those plans
seem to have changed, and at this point, we'd
be surprised if they ever went back to it.
If audiences cared so little about Solo, it's
hard to imagine them getting excited for Boba
Fett.
Imagine a movie that combined cowboys, ninjas,
and Vikings, starring Chris Pratt in the lead
role as the cowboy-ninja-viking.
Sounds fun enough, right?
Well, it wasn't meant to be.
Based on a 2009 limited series from Image
Comics, Cowboy Ninja Viking was announced
by Universal Pictures in 2017, and then delayed
indefinitely in August 2018, only a month
before production had been set to start.
Pratt was slated to play the main character
Duncan, a super-soldier with a personality
disorder, splitting his identity into three
distinct power sets.
It was originally set for release in June
2019 with a budget of around $65 million,
but was reportedly plagued by script issues
which helped lead to its collapse.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, rumors
of the film's impending shutdown flew around
Hollywood for months, meaning it wasn't too
much of a surprise that the movie didn't come
together even if it is disappointing for fans
of the comic.
Supernatural goth comic adaptation The Crow
hit theaters in 1994, and it feels like Hollywood
has been trying to remake the movie ever since.
But every time it starts to come together,
the project hits a wall.
A revolving door of actors have been attached
or been rumored to be attached to the role
of undead avenger Eric Draven, which was first
made popular by Brandon Lee.
The list includes Tom Hiddleston, Alexander
Skarsgard, Luke Evans, Jack Huston and more
and that's not even getting into all of the
potential directors who have come and gone.
Production was finally set to begin in 2015
before the bankruptcy of production company
Relativity Media shut the project down.
By late 2016, financing had reportedly been
secured for another attempt with Jason Momoa
in the lead role and The Nun's Corin Hardy
in the director's chair.
In March 2018, Variety reported that Sony
was setting a release date for The Crow for
October 2019 but just over two months later,
Deadline broke the news that Momoa and Hardy
had moved on.
Not long after that, Sony took the movie off
its schedule.
Neil Blomkamp made a huge impression in 2009
with his debut feature, the sci-fi parable
District 9.
While he's since produced two more full-length
movies with Elysium and Chappie, he also makes
short films with his company Oats Studio.
In 2017, the company made a 27-minute short
called "Firebase," set during the Vietnam
War and focusing on some American soldiers
who experience some very freaky occurrences.
"They were monsters… in the shape of men.”
"And they wouldn't die."
After the short was released online, it was
announced that the studio planned to adapt
it into a full-length feature, if a crowdfunding
drive was successful enough.
Long story short, it wasn't.
In April 2018, Oats Studios tweeted the news
that the longer version of "Firebase" was
dead, and that all contributors would have
their money refunded.
As they wrote in their since-deleted message,
"Unfortunately we didn't raise enough to do
something truly awesome.
We would rather over-deliver than create an
average film.
We thank the thousands of people who did back
us."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.